in less than two weeks voters will head
to the polls in West Virginia to vote
for the Republican they think may have
the best chance at beating Democrats
Senator Joe Manchin in the fall the
incumbent the top GOP candidates are out
trying to get the most votes but at
least one of them raising some
controversy over a comment he made about
someone in president Trump's cabinet
correspondent Peter Doocy has our report
from Charleston it was strange to see a
hat supporting Tom Willis for Senate on
the debate stage last night because Tom
Willis wasn't wearing it
he wasn't even invited instead the cap
was supported by his primary opponent
Don Blankenship who never took it off
he's a veteran he's a good guy he
deserves an equal chance now
Blankenship's latest attack on the
establishment is raising eyebrows
because the former coal baron who
recently did a year in jail on a
misdemeanor conviction tied to the Upper
Big Branch mine disaster that killed 29
is talking about the ethnicity of Labor
Secretary Elaine Chao the wife of
Senator Jordie leader Mitch McConnell I
have an issue when a person and there's
a lot of connections with some of the
branches if you live in China a Fox News
poll finds Blankenship trails
congressman Evan Jenkins and Attorney
General Patrick Morrissey Evan Jenkins
is a liberal fraud evan jenkins spent 20
years as a career Liberal Democrat
supporting Nancy Pelosi John Kerry
rallying for Hillary Clinton Morrissey
locked horns last night with Jenkins
over regulations with your New Jersey
approach of trying to interrupt why
don't you let me finish
Jenkins regularly reminds Republicans
that Morrissey ran for Congress in New
Jersey at the turn of the century
he also denigrates Morrissey is someone
with New Jersey values yes I called him
out in kind of a fun way at the debate
last night because he was just as pushy
kind of Jersey
values approach you know he's Jersey
through and through by his own admission
so here in the Mountain State not much
love for the Garden State and candidates
are actually running out of time to
change voters minds because early voting
starts today
that means that some West Virginians
have heard enough and they are casting
ballots that cannot be swayed in the
next two weeks by controversial comments
or expensive attack ads right Peter
Doocy in Charleston Peter thank you